okay so squid game is packed with easter
eggs hidden details and a lot of clues
that hint towards its eventual reveal
the show has taken the world by storm
and after watching it three times since
its release we've come across some
mind-blowing details in it that make it
even better heavy spoilers ahead so if
you haven't seen it then i'm putting a
red light on the video right now if you
enjoy the breakdown then please smash
the thumbs up button and make sure you
subscribe for videos like this each and
every day without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
squid game breakdown
okay so the opening of squid game may be
confusing at first we watch as the
convoluted rules are explained and see
kids play it who are of course gihon and
sang woo this flashback is key as it
foreshadows how the game will end which
was of course with a round of squid game
we jump forward to an adulkie hun who we
learn is a lifelong gambler that's
always betting on the wrong horse due to
his addiction and need to make his life
better he's actually the perfect person
to participate in the games the idea of
him betting on horses of course
foreshadows the future as it's explained
to him that squid game is very much the
same thing just with people being the
ones that are bet on in a way he's
similar to the southern gentleman vip
who keeps picking the wrong contestant
this would foreshadow junhoe's death at
the hands of the front man as the vip
would say i always pick losers he picked
junhoe to pleasure him only for the
character to turn around and attack him
john holes and caught out in this
quote-unquote game of life and death and
he's apparently killed though i am still
hashtag junhoe is still alive naokihon
uses the lucky numbers of six and eight
to win which they do however these
numbers appear many times in the show
they always represent the middle of the
herd in a race and the numbers also
appear in this fashion just before the
bridge challenge as one of the vips
explains everyone goes for the middle
and that is to find safety when
threatened it's better to stay amongst
the people instead of taking your own
risks but that strategy also proves to
be very very stupid six also appears
again as there are six games that take
place over six days and the religious
player would later choose the number six
as it represents the day god made humans
and christianity funnily enough gehan
won 4.56 million at the horse track and
this moment is just some amazing
attention to detail now sabia does end
up helping gihon later on in the bridge
game and this may be her paying him back
after she pickpockets him early on
gihon's nice nature would be
foreshadowed as even after being chased
by violent loan sharks he would help her
when he thought she simply fell over now
these loan sharks offer some interesting
parallels when they threaten gihon's
kidney this is similar to how the body
parts of the losers in the game would be
harvested off and it lends way to the
theory that they're all actually working
for illness down on his luck he needs 10
000 won for a present for his kid which
is the same money he gave as a tip to
the betting shop teller this figure
would be constant for kihon as after
winning the game and having billions he
withdraws just 10 000 won the prize
itself is in a box similar to those that
the dead bodies are kept in and it makes
for an amazing easter egg in this scene
now unfortunately due to his money
problems gehan cannot afford to give his
daughter a fancy dinner she's given what
her mother perceives as junk food and
says how his stepfather bought her steak
dinner which puts further pressure on
him to get money gihan status was too
low to afford it but he would finally be
able to have a fancy dinner before the
final game but it was just as miserable
as this one now from here his paths
cross with the squid game recruiter who
gives him two options gihon can either
play as red or blue and though it seems
like a pretty shallow choice there may
be other layers to it he chooses blue
and ends up as a player but the red card
is very similar to the colour of the
gods uniforms now whilst the gods seem
like they're in control they're forced
to obey the rules and also killed for
even showing their faces they sleep in
cells and are given numbers too so it is
possible that they're all part of the
operation just like the players the game
theme is kept up throughout the gods
cctv terminals as they're shaped like
sit-down arcade cabinets in the series
we learn that it's been about 33 years
of games so far so it makes sense that
illness would get this inspiration from
the popular arcades of yesteryear the
god symbols also have a lot of
connections to gaming with the triangle
circle and square reminding me of a
playstation controller each shape does
have meaning too as circles are workers
triangles are soldiers and squares are
the managers the amount of angles on
your helmet also denote your hierarchy
as well with no shapes being the lowest
tier the front man has many contours and
the vips have a ridiculous amount right
up to the southern gentleman who appears
to have the highest out of all of them
which is why he can do what he wants
healing's mask also has a massive amount
on them but we'll talk about that later
on in the video now squares circles and
triangles also appear throughout the
series at numerous points when the group
play red light green light we can see
them above the gate at the door next to
the gates are fake metal windows and
these are made up of the shapes circles
triangles and squares the card also has
the shapes on them and the layout of
squid game is of course made up of
squares circles and triangles when
illness visits his quote-unquote house
in the marbles game you can also catch
the shapes on the gates outside of it
further hinting to him being the one
who's behind it now back to the game and
the idea of people playing with their
bodies is set up here as every time that
gihan loses he gets a painful slap but
if he wins he gets money now i'm not
sure how lucky gee honey is getting the
chance to play a game for billions it's
out of nope right out there just seeing
the creepy doll for red light green
light however if the series hasn't
ruined your life you can visit the doll
at maca land horse carriage museum now
speaking of people whose lives have been
ruined the guy whose number is on the
card has also complained that he's
received non-stop calls since the show
aired and i feel so sorry for him now
with his winnings with a recruiter gihon
heads off to treat his mother which is
reminiscent of how sang we would ask
kihan to give his mother money before he
ended his life in the final game gihon
goes to get picked up and the password
is red light green light which
foreshadows the first game upon waking
up gihan realizes that his number is
4-5-6 signifying that he's the lowest
there with illnam the game's architect
being number one ilnam even translates
to first man or number one man giving us
an indication of his status the prize
money is of course divisible by gihon's
number and this gives us a further clue
to one being in charge gehun didn't pick
up on him saying he knew what was going
on and he underestimated him instantly
much like how we all did the pair also
meet with gihon standing over ilnam as
he's in a bed which mirrors the final
scene that the two share together now
inside the room with all the beds we get
a clue on the walls as to what each game
will actually be however in a dark twist
of fate the clues only fully start to
reveal themselves when people die after
red light green light however we see
every single game on the wall which ends
with the final one being the squid game
now music is a prominent part of the
show with this song blue danube being
played before and after each and every
game this piece of music by johann
strauss ii was commissioned and later
urged to be light in a beat as his
nation austria had lost to prussia in
the seven week war this was intended to
keep players upbeat before and after the
slaughter much like the citizens of
austria after that conflict other parts
of the preamble before going to the game
are the cartoony bright coloured stairs
which are similar to images created by
m.c escher his work of infinite and
wacky stairs symbolizes the monotony of
climbing up for nothing it matches up
here as the contestants are in a loop
and also most of the time climbing up
for nothing illness is the key in the
red light green light game as he smiles
showing he's happy and more alive than
ever we know he was in hospital as
that's where he would later be picked up
from but unlike the other contestants he
would not be gassed he is smiling as
it's probably the last time he'll play
one of his favorite games and he's
enjoying being a participant instead of
a watcher the creepy girl robot has a
squid game called hairpin in her hair
and we are treated to another hint that
illness is special as he's not scanned
by her each of the players gets a green
overlay indicating that they're a target
however illness is completely fine and
probably not in any danger interestingly
the person directly next to him isn't
highlighted either and it is possible
that he has a protective ring around him
so that the machine can't even fire
close to him in case it kills him by
accident now the father-son-esque
relationship between illness hun is one
of the most enthralling parts of the
show when they aren't helping each other
they are always incredibly close and
finishing games by seconds it happens in
the red light green light game with
illness gloating that he beat him but it
would later reverse in marbles with
gehun taking that his death bed is where
the final game between the two takes
place and gihon would beat him with
seconds to go as the character passes
away though we will never know if he
knew that he lost the game it doesn't
matter as this final scene shows that
people will help one another and that
there is decency beyond what he believed
it also paints the two as opposites and
sets up gihan trying to take down the
squid game now illness also gives a hint
that the pair might be related as kihon
says he can't drink the milk and instead
asks for chocolate ilnam says that his
son used to do the same thing and that
he'd beat him for it on a personality
level it's possible that the two also
echo one another as both leave their
families in order to get involved with
the games now the vote to continue the
game leads to some very very interesting
moments and it contains buttons that are
green and red the vote starts in reverse
order which makes gihon seem important
but really it's done to ensure that
ilnam has the deciding vote should it
come down to it sangwoo and ali end up
in town together and this foreshadows
their partnership in the marble game at
this point the 10 000 one appears again
as it's the amount sangwoo gives to poor
ali in this moment yeah it's not all you
you give to him is it you traitor now in
this hiatus a number of deaths are also
foreshadowed duck sue jumped off a
bridge to escape the gangsters and he
would later die after falling off the
glass bridge ali took the money from his
boss but he was later eliminated when
sangwoo stole his marbles savior would
threaten a man with a knife to his neck
but would die the same way bringing
everything full circle from this on top
of this sangui tried to end his life in
a bathtub wearing a tuxedo and this full
shadow is his final act in which he does
this in the rain dextoo's minions would
turn on him and lose respect for him
just like the marble game and it's sort
of like poetry they rhyme ha do one of
those now during the quote unquote
chance meeting with ilnam and gihon
ilnam says her outside is torture
hinting that he would rather be inside
enjoying his creation porgy hun also
meets his ex-wife and leaves his
umbrella by accident at their flat this
gives us a hint at him always for
getting his umbrella which he says is
his reason for choosing the shape in the
now tick-tock famous honeycomb game now
there's also one key moment here that
becomes so heartbreaking once you finish
the show june ho spends the episode
following up on leads about the game and
tracks dengue hun and asks him for help
to find out what's going on gee hun
could have actually put an end to the
game at this point but instead he
participates in it and wins which puts
him on a course to attempt to end things
anyway the players all return and it
seems like ilnam wasn't actually knocked
out as we see him moving whilst he
should be asleep we start to see the
form of our squad in episode 3 and
illness further hints he is powerful by
saying he won't die easily which yes he
won't he's referred to as the old mager
who's been in the army all our life and
as we learn he's been running the squid
game for years in another slight hint
ilnam says that their meals are
essentially what his wife would make him
and their kids for lunch which further
ties the setup to him sangwoo's morality
breakdown also starts here in the
honeycomb game as he allowed people to
basically get shapes that would leave
them in very difficult positions duke
continues his theme of turning on people
after they help him by accepting the
lighter and 111's doctor skills are
shown for the first time as he handles
the game with ease this makes sense
while he's later taken to harvest organs
for the gods and it's nice that it's set
up here the scale of this inside job is
shown as one of the guards deletes
footage at the start of episode 4
showing there was more illegal activity
inside the organization itself
get it organization
organization anyway moving on now some
of the characters are fascinating mirror
images as well with sai biak and mianyao
being opposite sides of the same coin
also yeah i'm apologies for butchering
all these names now while both the
desperate survivors and ruthless even
when helping each other cyborg sees
being a lone wolf is the best means to
getting to survive whilst miano uses her
craziness and tenacity to blend in with
the strongest it's why she says she's
good at things unless she's not because
she uses other people's skills as the
honeycomb game wraps up we see how john
hoe learns the hierarchy as he's scorned
for being in the wrong place later on he
swaps costumes with his manager which is
why he has power later however the
doctor is fully in with the guards and
you can actually tell they try and keep
some alive during the executions so that
later on he can harvest the organs from
their bodies easier further hints that
the game is rigged for illness happen as
the brawl is called off instantly when
he says that he's scared his bed is also
the only one that isn't flipped showing
the respect that those in authority have
for him meow nyo has a little coitus
session with the gangster and he says
how he thinks that she will be
responsible for his death that night
while he didn't die when he predicted
she does kill him in the end she is
mugged off quite a lot during the tug of
war game and is forced to seek a new
team who call her old woman further
hints about the illness twist occur here
as he knows how to win at tug of war the
guy is an expert in all of the games as
he of course played them when he was
growing up now during the tug of war
scene we even see a hint of how illnan
would have escaped should his team have
failed each person has locks on them to
attach them to the rope which is of
course what ensures you go down with
your team however though illness
initially had locks like the rest of the
team they are gone when he wins it shows
he would have just slipped off the rope
if it came down to it and shout out to
youtuber maxi doxie for spotting this
really cool detail now it's around this
time that junho also uncovers the data
on the games and when looking through
the files the 2021 starts at number two
instead of one this further hints
towards illness being off the books and
actually in charge as he's not keeping
records on himself after the game it's
all foreshadows how illnam angie hun's
relationship will go as the ladder gives
him something to cover his wet trousers
i think illnam actually tricked everyone
with this as beside his head you can
catch an empty bottle of water which he
likely tipped over his pants however
guillen is extremely kind here and stays
behind to help him illness then
reciprocates it by giving gihon the
number one jacket which may foreshadow
how he could end up in control of the
games some have said how this is to
protect him as the gods won't do
anything to harm player one on top of
this i see as a changing of the guard as
the most important players are swapping
place and it's very much a passing of
the torch gihon's kindness is shown once
more as he opts to play with illness in
a team game whereas everyone thinks you
need someone strong he didn't want him
to die due to being the odd one out
potentially getting executed and thus he
picked him to be by his side ironically
gihon's kindness actually quote unquote
killed ilnam or at least it ended the
game for him
whilst he didn't die if he'd simply left
him ilam simply would have skipped this
round and went through to the next one
ilnam would have definitely known this
and this is why the day before he
pretended to be very ill and also weak
when the selection process was going on
he also sat at the back rejected being
chosen and then moved out the way in
order to avoid being picked as a player
he's the only one who didn't go looking
for someone to team up with because he
knew that remaining behind would be a
free pass illness once more shows his
knowledge and connection to the games by
saying that the marble one takes place
in the area where he used to live he
goes looking for his house and comes
across a perfect recreation of it which
lets us know that it was modeled on the
home he used to have interestingly gihon
also says that the alleyway in it
resembles where he used to live so
potentially this is another clue to them
being father and son now a big hint that
he drops here is that illness says he
used to stand behind a pole and watch
his sun and their friends play games
together this was completely unbeknownst
to them and it murdered the way that
ilnam would watch the players in the
game without them knowing however he
also says that he really wanted to play
with them which mirrors how he would
enter the games in order to participate
in the marvel's game qiyon is paired
with sebiyuk they talk about the
possibility of leaving and going on an
island retreat together and in a brutal
twist of dramatic irony they were all of
course on an island together gehun does
show his gambling addiction once more as
illnam knows that he will bet it all
just for a chance to win now if ali's
dead that didn't rip your heart out
seeing poor illness die was gut
wrenching as gihan had to go to the dark
side and abandon his morals knowing what
we know now it becomes obvious that
illinois wasn't killed at this point as
not only is he the only player that we
don't see die but there's also no blood
or a body when we cut to the wide shot
now illness reveals himself as the owl
in episode 7 which makes so much sense
as we see his hands which look just like
his the owl is fitting as it's a spare
animal and is wise and fiercely
intelligent having a spare animal of an
owl can bring you luck which matches up
really well with the character as he
brings wisdom and luck throughout the
entire game notably illnam doesn't meet
with the rest of the vips as he's had
his fix and decided that watching is
just enough for now at the end of the
show he said he made the game for
entertainment and now he's finally had
the itch scratched so to speak which
does explain his absence during the
bridge game we have to mention that it's
human nature to hide in a pack of people
this has been a theme of the show as
groups formed amongst the contestants
and this obsession with being in a group
or team has now become their downfall
due to how the bridge game works being
cautious and at the back finally pays
off after being the worst strategy and
it means that gihon has the easiest time
now should ill name have made it at this
point i think that the lights would have
been left on so that he could see the
thickness of the glass and perhaps he
didn't want to do this game as yeah
those heights are terrifying once the
bridge game is over we are left with our
three survivors and it makes for an
amazing couple of final episodes they
are treated like vips and then given a
steak dinner calling back to gihon's
daughter obviously they have ranked up
as the food is opulent and they're given
fancy clothes so they no longer have to
wear the green track suits they are at a
triangle table and if you recall the
triangle is a step above the average
worker for the gods it's a subtle hint
they've been promoted based on their
game performance and it sort of just
ties everything together sadly my
favorite character gets taken out and
we're left with just two the final game
is squid game and just like the one with
the recruiter they're given a choice of
offense or defense after the last death
we see a big change with gihon no longer
playing cautiously and at the back this
time he chooses offense signifying his
change to be a more offensive player
which we will also see at the end with
his rip-roaring rampage of revenge
beginning gehun ends up winning and this
calls back to the beginning in which he
also took that once all is said and done
yay gihon has his winnings and if it was
me yeah i'd have bought a shiny
charizard and a hell of a lot of funko
pops the limited edition ones with the
chase the chase sticker on them now the
front man toasts to him and explains the
horse metaphor due to the findings at
the end of episode 5 we know that he was
also a player and that he likely won
because he's still alive perhaps he
became bored with his winnings and ended
up joining the game in order to oversee
it the front man ilnam and gihon are all
people that ended up putting their
family to the side in order to be part
of the games and it decides that there's
these little parallels going on with all
the characters the front man is somewhat
an opposite to gihon as both are winners
but one chose to participate in an
authority role while sierra wants to
take the organization down i do think
that jun ho is alive as he's shot in the
same spot as inho and the latter does
survive so it makes sense that he would
too potentially he's had to lay low for
a year to wait for the games to start
again so that he can gather evidence as
it was all likely destroyed during his
escape gehun withdraws 10 000 won again
with this being the amount that was
needed at the start to impress his
daughter
after his mother's death we get a time
jump at one year and see that his life
hasn't changed all that much similar to
the vips he's found little enjoyment in
the fortune that he's been blessed with
and he's just very very miserable
however the big reveal happens which is
one of the most tense scenes i think
i've ever seen illness the surrogate
father figure in the game for gihon is
revealed to be the architect and oh my
god who saw this coming i didn't i know
some of you in the comments did but i
definitely didn't now we learned that he
was simply bored and needed
entertainment and i don't know why he
didn't just go to space like the rich
man in the west the connection between
the pair continues as illness was a
moneylender and gihon was of course a
victim of them of course each contestant
had debts but gehuns was literally as a
result of debts to moneylenders so
illnam very much forced him through it
all as his puppet they play one last
game to see if humanity is truly good
which thank god it turns out to be after
this gihon decides to go on a revenge
tour and he dies his hair red the
director talked about this matter with
the radio times and said that gihan's
red hair represents that he will never
be able to go back to his old self and
it's also a sign of his rage red is of
course the color that was associated
with the gods in the games and it shows
how he's very much switched from a
player into an authority position it's
the perfect way to end the show and
seeing the games are still going on
leaves you very hyped for next time
overall this might be one of the most
complex shows today on netflix as each
set up a shot has a purpose and reason
behind it it's very much a lightning in
the bottle series that has struck a
chord that's made it a complete global
phenomenon the game itself is of course
a metaphor for how the rich play with
the lives of normal people and there's a
lot of similarities to capitalism and
how many are clamoring over each other
whilst the ritual all overall it was
fantastic and if you spotted anything we
missed then i'd love to hear it below we
are running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the phase 3
mcu boxset on the 30th of october and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the series we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of all the
theories that we have on the show
including the cards one everything
that's going on and yeah it's absolutely
bonkers so go head over there right
after this if not then thank you for
sending you this video i've been paul
and i'll see you next time take care
peace